Moi, depuis que j'ai un iPhone, enfin, un smartphone,
je suis pas spécialement accro.
Enfin, j'arrive vraiment
à l'utiliser avec modération.
FAUX !
On se rend compte que le smartphone,
c'est vraiment une drogue.
Quand on passe une soirée
avec ses potes comme ça...
Ça vous dérange pas on fait
une photo pour Instagram ?
Ouais, OK.
>> Ouh, ouais ! [♪ musique ♪]
C'est vrai qu'avec les smartphones,
on dirait que les gens, ils kiffent plus la vraie vie.
Quand tu vas en concert, il y a tout le monde
qui filme et personne ne regarde le truc en live.
Alors qu'en plus, tu sais très bien que cette vidéo,
tu ne vas jamais la regarder.
Hé, mon gars, hier, j'étais à un concert,
c'était tellement énorme ! Mate !
Ah ouais ?
Et c'était quel groupe ?
Ah ça, je sais pas par contre,
je filmais, donc...
Mais j'avoue, moi-même, je suis tellement
habitué à être sur mon smartphone tout le temps,
qu'il y a des moments où, quand je l'utilise,
je ne m'en rends même plus compte.
13 € + 4 €, ce qui nous fait au total
deux de combien déjà ?
Attendez, je vous le fais de tête.
De tête, ça fait 13 + 4, euh 17.
Voilà !
Exactement !
Je crois que les personnes âgées,
elles sont pas très au courant
de tout ce qu'on peut faire avec un smartphone.
La dernière fois, j'ai demandé à une vieille dame
de me prendre en photo avec un pote,
je vous jure, elle a fait comme ça.
Allez les garçons, on se resserre,
on fait un sourire. Allez ! Cheese !
Je pense qu'elle est pas mal, hein.
On verra au développement,
mais je pense.
J'ai mon petit talent
de photographe.
Franchement, il existe un milliard
d'applications pour les smartphones,
mais elles sont toutes plus inutiles
les unes que les autres.
Attends, l'application boussole !
Y a vraiment un mec qui utilise ça ?
Ouais, Barnabé,
excuse-moi la question bête,
mais ce soir, on a bien
rendez-vous au Nord-Ouest ?
Ah d'accord, j'ai cru, j'ai cru Sud-Est,
n'importe quoi. À toute !
Alors, Nord-Ouest,
Nord-Ouest là, tout droit...
Je sais pas pourquoi, mais j'ai l'impression
que les mecs qui ont des iPhones,
ils s'en foutent complètement de toutes
les autres marques de smartphones.
Par contre, les mecs
qui ont des smartphones,
on sait pas pourquoi,
mais ils détestent tous les iPhones.
Ben moi, si tu veux, mon Nexus,
il fait 600 millions de pixels par photo,
je sais pas si tu réalises,
mais bon, quand j'entends dire
l'iPhone ceci, l'iPhone cela,
bon, ça me fait doucement sourire.
Entre collègues, on en ricane,
on en ricane, c'est ridicule.
Hé mec, tu veux
un iPhone 5S gratuit ?
Oh ouais, s'il te plaît ! Vas-y,
s'il te plaît, donne ! S'il te plaît !
Mais à l'inverse, ceux qui n'ont
pas du tout de smartphone,
qui n'ont pas
les moyens d'en avoir,
à chaque fois, ils me font vraiment
culpabiliser d'en avoir un.
Le dernier tweet de François Hollande,
il est énorme, regarde !
Bah non, je ne peux pas. Moi, j'ai pas
de smartphone, moi. Moi, j'ai que ça.
Que cette merde.
Ah. Ben tu sais, toute façon,
ça c'est des conneries, hein.
Le plus important, c'est
que tu puisses téléphoner avec.
Non, même pas.
Le mien, il donne que l'heure.
Hum.
Mais je suis tellement habitué à biper
mon téléphone dès que je le perds quelque part,
que maintenant, dès que je perds un truc,
j'ai envie de le biper.
J'ai envie de biper mes clés,
j'ai envie de biper la télécommande
et même parfois,
j'ai envie de biper
Cergy ! Cergy !
OK.
[vibreur]
♪ Bonjour. Vous êtes bien
sur le répondeur ♪
♪ de Cergy. Merci de laisser
un message. ♪
Il saoule !
Les smartphones, c'est censé simplifier la vie,
mais en fait, ça la complique.
Avec la correction d'orthographe,
par exemple, quand t'écris des mots,
ton portable, il décide tout seul
d'envoyer d'autres mots à ta place.
Salut Juliette. C'était sympa
ce petit ciné. J'espère à bientôt.
Je vais tuer toute ta famille
avec un lance-grenades, car je suis néonazi.
Ouin !
Mais tout le monde est un peu accro
au smartphone, hein !
C'est comme ça, c'est normal. C'est juste
parce que c'est nouveau que ça choque les gens.
Moi, je suis sûr qu'à l'époque où ils ont inventé le livre,
ça a dû choquer tout le monde au début.
Jason, arrête de faire ton geek.
>> Papa, j'ai lu que trois pages aujourd'hui.
>> T'as lu trois pages ? Mais moi, tu crois
qu'à ton âge, je lisais des pages ?
Putain, je comprends rien ! Moi, à ton âge,
je mangeais des cailloux !
Ah, c'est pour ça que t'as plus de dent !
[claque]
Pédé !
Merci d'avoir regardé ma vidéo.
N'hésitez pas à lâcher un petit commentaire
si vous voulez vous exprimer
ou simplement à vous abonner
à ma chaîne YouTube, c'est gratuit.
Voilà ! Allez, à bientôt !
Hé ! Quelqu'un peut me sortir d'ici,
s'il vous plaît ?
♪ Je ne suis plus gentil,
Luigi sort la Kalash. ♪
♪ Pendant son sommeil,
je vais lui refaire la moustache. ♪
♪ On verra bientôt qui sera le champion
quand je te ferai avaler ces 200 champignons. ♪
♪ L-U-I-G-I
Mon nom c'est Luigi. ♪
♪ Here we, here we go,
c'est la fin de Mario ♪
♪ L-U-I-G-I
Mon nom c'est Luigi. ♪